Rhianna works it for vogue the superstar
stuns on the June cover of the fashion
management folks fans we're gonna have
some fun today so okay and inside the
glossy she gets candid about her
relationship with Drake apparently his
speech at the 2016 of Video Music Awards
made things awkward of between the two
she's somewhat I've been in love with
since I was 22 years old
RiRi tells Vogue quote that speech was
probably the most uncomfortable part I
don't like too many compliments I don't
like to be put on blast
[Music]
Rihanna says today she and Drake aren't
friends but they're not enemies either
as for a man who is in her life the 30
year old confirms to Vogue that she is
in a relationship though she wouldn't it
directly named her man who is rumored to
be Saudi businessman Hassan Jamil
instead the Barbadian beauty simply
shared her philosophy on love quote I
used to feel guilty about taking
personal time but I also think I never
met someone who was worth it before I'm
glad I'm taking the time I'm happy
[Music]